[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so we can't remember sitting to the
[ __ ] thing
[Applause]
- my thinking much
and one got the shower like your dick
that was that your uncle say
[Music]
and I
[Applause]
Carrie come on
[Applause]
[Applause]
commander in circuit course I'm nervous
because it hurt me
I want a handy
[Music]
is that what you learned in eight years
of this holy [ __ ] I do that if we're
gonna take that really is it he's
definitely he's usually pretty
[Applause]
well your wife my mates outgrown okay
so they diagnosed me and I being real in
the operating room a nurse there at
surgery doctors yeah Smitty average then
we were meeting into the operator and
I'm about 15 feet outside Network I'm
stair and I passed a sign on the wall to
the test
please make sure you have the right
patient
[Applause]
[Music]
I said we got
slow down
[Applause]
[Music]
even and I will be there I can help on
the way into the operating room now is
another sign all the operators are doing
but that you top please remember your
left is their college 47 years know your
left from your right now I'm
legitimately here
it's just me the Indian CEO and there's
that sign on every wall we share
recognition let's mention and at this
point I'm almost why is that
you're the scared mom
I also say other to go to med school
just so I can make some room to room 9
every second
I'm gonna like practical jokes that may
be the best one I've ever heard
you're gonna
[Applause]
goodnight
and it's like 3:00 this morning and I
want two days of percocet so tired but
I'm also really high model a new deal I
remember when I walked in the day before
a check-in got games Bob
she's about it and you leave my side
bets I'm gonna come pick it up but you
know the basket there you always buy me
the bottle and leave it on the side of
my bed you have that surgery
[Music]
you just walk into that
my tank for people insurance and my
hang-up on what could use
dr. heated bottle from the [ __ ] day
right the nurse walked in one I was
standing next to my bed
[Applause]
what I call the matters now like for
designers this is really tall muscular
woman and really high I was actually
[Music]
[Applause]
but this young cute
23 year old nurse he has a very happy
marriage I will tell you the festival
[Applause]
my duplicate so many days a google.sdl
honey
twenty-three-year-old 1ci straight
[Music]
my hair
pretty cool she walked in like one girl
hold the dribble bladder
morality mommy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the nurses have reason to squeeze top of
my toe
did you make a mess
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm in a mess
[Music]
she said why do you well
maybe the little master
she walks over to where my headed pets
it twice like good dog again with this
bird how old do you think I am
and guys my masculinity was just getting
chopped down
and return until the counter I'll walk
you right now you know I mean
the game I play
nurse nurse she said master on she's
been sick before and actually that's it
there wasn't Hey
that's it let me get you up walk around
today and she said that [ __ ] finally
all right sunny who appreciates my
specific set of skills she said we had
some the opiates you backed up there's
no way that you go home unless we know
your patent pass something through so
I'm gonna need your car
but she said and then she said to me I'm
a nurse just know you farted in front of
me he's the worst thing to happen to me
today this would be the best day I've
ever had
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so yeah right and the natural the blower
like a reckoning you know and I got my
dog
[Music]
and I start to show the stitches and
I've never had surgery
like a child
Jhansi memory
stupid okay
I get around time to feel the movement
going she said you know what you should
be shot she said walk too fast now I'm
gonna tell you my theory on that but
before we go any further when you tell
you takes eight weeks to heal I think
that means four weeks I think you're
banging you cover your own ass if you
tell me to take two pills I takes out
[Music]
that number has increased
she's hit for round three Emmys beat up
making my stride I'm speeding up and I
speed stuff to work a little
[Music]
we get right around angry
I'm skip
I said no not a good job
you and I have a different definition a
good job right now because what's in my
man sells goods like I did a great job
guys I can't be dropping the deuce in
welcoming that's how things get started
on the internet everybody I gotta get to
my room which is here so I get around
this kind let's take a walk back and she
says to me oh you walking fast enough
and I think what I said to her was don't
talk to me I couldn't even have words
concentration on my [ __ ] to make sure
nothing bad how do you work that no
words no concentration I can focus right
now 100%
[Music]
they comment this way is one nurse and I
met a couple times you're big boys yeah
her face will tell me if she knows
there's nobody you guys you see it as
normal human being
John sociopath
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's you know the same poison I hear how
you gonna say great see you later
I'm running around think I'm unaware of
attachment
walk walk myself up throw that trash I
also to the rest of town
[Music]
[Applause]
and I put on through the eight pairs
mother where the nurse night before
[Music]
she probably hate their coverage I
handed it to me and she goes act
[Music]
well you are area
there you know and nobody knows I'm off
Scott now he loves me
I've been peeing above I've never used
the bathroom it's as clean as the day as
I walked in we're buddies man I don't
know what he looks like
do I look like a skirt though John and
he always walks in goes what's up wolf
and I don't you what's up man
he say he walks and he goes what's up
what's up man and he walks into the back
[Music]
[Applause]
seriously you're that door shut come
inside you hear good god the door flies
over man runs up here that's a meeting
you like to [ __ ] all over his mouth her
and then I heard this story so I told
you be [ __ ] in the hallway
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you